yeah I think we just missed being in the
southern part of the us we miss all of
the lacrosse we miss all of the you know
the sports really the the the the uh
whatever it's called the difference of
sports just changes over you know as you
go down south but you know um I was
talking earlier about how popular hockey
is and it's definitely huge in our
country but if you were to go around
anywhere and interview people outside of
Canada and say what is the national
sport of Canada they'd all say ice
hockey or 90% of them but it's lacrosse
but it's actually lacrosse lacrosse was
invented in Six Nations Reserve which is
just outside of my hometown of Branford
so a couple things we're very proud of
Alexander green bell made his first
phone call from Branford my hometown did
he really yes who' he call he called
somebody in Paris Ontario which was like
a 15 uh minutes away 15 miles away
probably a chick I bet that who you
going to call if you get your first call
you're going to call probably some woman
you or you know some lady you might want
to say you know and so they actually
have the telephone I don't know in in in
Branford no yeah and uh the other thing
is we're very proud of was that lacrosse
was invented in in Canada it was it was
a great sport yeah dude I didn't even
know about can I mean I didn't even when
I was growing up we didn't even really
believe in Canada you know listen I I
will tell you this in Canada and I don't
mean this to be controversial we learn
growing up the geography of pretty the
world but a lot of Canada in the United
States where American Kids kind of grow
up they didn't learn a whole lot about
Canada that there's provinces like a lot
of Canadian kids can name every state in
every Capital but there's only a handful
of people I know that can name all the
provinces probably 70 people that in
America I'm not even joking I remember
in our school we learned about America
right some kids can barely do that but
then above it on the map they had a
picture of a it was like a wolf chasing
a boy you know and that was and we're
like what is that and they're like
that's you know that's Canada one of the
one of the first things I learned was
the capital of Louisiana Baton Rouge oh
yeah I always remember that I don't know
why I remember that but I did it's a
pretty good place they had a hockey team
for a little while didn't do well but
you know I grew up in the South there's
a lot of like I don't know if there's
still as much but especially when I was
growing up there was like more racial
disparity down there you know cuz
there's a lot of history of like black
and white racism down there and um and
when I was in Canada I don't feel that
energy I I don't everybody seems the
same it's like I say that to people that
we just we don't seem to have racism in
our country people all seem to get along
you know and
it's that's why people always come up to
me and they say you're from Canada right
and I say yeah they like Canadians are
all so nice and I go yeah I think they
are and I said but you know I got five
American Kids five American
grandchildren and they're all nice kids
too so you can meet a lot of nice people
in the United States yeah I think in the
South well the south is also kind of
religious there's more religion there
you know and the only person we've ever
seen even kind of or the only person
that people believe like behaves like or
gets Wild on water is the Jesus really
so I think the second you see a guy
saying hey look what I'm going to do out
here on this frozen lake I think it
makes you wonder what's going on here
well in Canada we call our Arenas
churches oh yeah because you know Canada
it's hockey and religion those are the
two biggest things right so you can be
you know Sports is very popular in our
country football Canadian football
baseball the Blue Jays do well the
Raptors have done really well so it's
kind of Canada's team the Raptors in the
Blue Jays yeah but hockey is everywhere
right so you can be driving in your car
in July and if you're listening to talk
radio it's still 90% hockey that they're
talking about June July and August cuz
you can still do it
and it's so popular right oh yeah people
love it people I think it's unbelievable
yeah it's you know like down down in the
US I always encourage parents to tell
their kids play every sport tennis
baseball football basketball soccer uh
field lacrosse and they're all so big
and if you sat down here you would say
Okay baseball is probably the most
popular sport or no it's basketball is
the biggest sport yeah and then you're
like well football's pretty big but in
Canada there's no definition it's one
it's ice hockey it's hocke that's it I
always see when guys get traded up there
more basketball than baseball and guys
well I don't want to play in Canada I
want to stay in my own country but the
guys who go there will tell you they get
treated phenomenally it's a great city
to live in it's a great country and
people are nice oh okay people's always
so nice in Canada even if somebody was
angry they may I bet they would they'd
come across the street and they just say
hey I'm angry but but I'm sorry yeah you
there's a lot of sories up there yeah
they're just too kind I remember I went
to Florida so I was in Florida right
I've been on a cruise ship and I had to
go to Edmonton to perform right at the
comedy club there oh yeah it was like
one of the first been in there oh yeah
in uh at the Mall of America right or
Mall of of Canada yeah he built that one
before the one in Minnesota well that
one first of all you guys has a gun
range in it which isn't crazy you know
and we got a we got a lake with waves we
got a hockey ring in there it's pretty
much everything in there yeah yeah yeah
there's like four American Eagles in
there and there actually there was an
actual American Eagle in there last time
we were in there yeah and it was
hatching it was doing like a um I think
it had had a couple of chicklings or
whatever near Payless Shoes yeah I I've
never been a hunter you know hunting
duck hunting big in your country huh
it's big in Alberta big in saset one we
went hunting one time I went one time in
my life went with three teammates we
were 19 years old we didn't know what we
were doing and uh we're 2 hours in we
were duck hunting and we couldn't figure
out where the Ducks were and this guy
come over and he said you guys got a
goose
call that's how bad our hunting was and
we're standing there going we just
thought there was no ducks yeah you look
over just Tony SRA Goose there you got
the wrong you got the wrong horn or
whatever I'm like okay that was my last
time I had to go to this store it was $5
to get a permit I never even fired the
gun was the last time I ever went never
shot a gun gun since I'm trying to think
of a first concert dber went to might
have been like Smashing Pumpkins or
something well our big ones up there are
Pink Floyd and oh yeah the hit and
tragically hip tragically hip yeah Brian
Adams and of course oh dude I met Brian
Adams in South Africa at a breakfast
buffet um and uh he's a wonderful guy
and of course Seline Deon oh yeah she
was uh Burton Cummings was big in Canada
Burton Cummings yeah they were in a band
called The Guess Who it's funny funny
cuz my my friends and all laugh at me
because every time somebody comes on
whether it's a singer or an actor or
whatever I'll go you know he's Canadian
like there's so many people that you
don't know that are Canadian that I know
yeah I go he's Canadian you know there's
so many greats Jim Cary M um hoe Mandel
yeah there there's a lot of really good
Canadians Canada doesn't Revere
celebrity it's different right than in
America they do oh they do they're
listen Canadians are very proud of their
country right no oh yeah no doubt but if
yeah there's something they like the
story B like my Canadian friends love
stories like bizel mourer is Canadian
and he loves like the there's always
like yeah but this guy you know like
they love the uh well right now
probably Drake's probably our biggest
Canadian right now say he's probably
he's probably the he's a closest thing
right now to to Taylor Swift I would
imagine Drake or
Santa
no Drake's pretty big I got to meet
Drake last weekend actually yeah at a
concert no it was um I was hanging out
with this guy David grutman he's like a
okay he's a restaurant tour I was
hanging out with this restaurant tour
guy I was in Miami okay and Drake had
had some uh was having like a little get
together in a bar that he rented out a
small bar and he knew it so he went by
and he and I had messaged each other
what's that what city were you in in uh
Miami Florida okay he and I had mess oh
yeah he had a concert there last week
bunch of our friends drove down for the
concert from where from Canada no no we
live in Jupiter oh you do Fort
Lauderdale area oh it's pretty over
there yeah yeah see I I got to Florida
once and I just stayed it's nice isn't
it I'm telling you I couldn't get there
as a kid but now I live there people
were on to it brother
yeah